[Applause]
i love your christmasy colors yeah yeah
you look fantastic yeah we all look our
best well i
i do not but thank you for including me
um so so much to talk about first of all
uh flight of the concords uh there's an
insane following for that show and of
course as well for the daily show there
must be a lot of people that look at you
and say you have overnight success you
just you you launched yourself
immediately into the public eye what's
the real story here well i guess
overnight success might work for anyone
who was in a coma for seven years
but it took a long time it took you a
while yeah and what what finally did you
think triggered it what finally got you
your big break was there a moment you
remember where things started to turn
around for you yeah there was um there
was an andy kaufman contest that the
kaufman family put on and it was for
comedians who are doing different things
with comedy pushing the envelope like
andy kaufman did because i would do
weird things like you know read
you know a diary from a suicidal
caterpillar you know who didn't think
that he would become a butterfly or
dressed up as a whoopee cushion
who's sad that they're a washed up joke
and just farted a lot and it just wasn't
really mainstream so you stole my act by
the way yeah
uh uh-huh so you did that yeah i did the
contest and um
and i won and they gave me a five
thousand dollar check but like a giant
check one of those big
prop checks jumbo checks yeah and so i
walked it was in at caroline's in times
square i walked across the street to the
restaurant that i was working at for two
years and i was like i quit
you know and uh and then i walked around
new york with a giant check and if you
ever feel like you don't have enough
attention just get a giant check because
everybody wants to talk to you you know
what's so crazy it's so it must be so
satisfying to quit your job holding a
giant check like yeah for five thousand
dollars i mean i could live for five
years at that point
well good for you you have obviously a
very unique voice
and uh you're getting work uh in uh in a
lot of animated uh features with this
voice is that not true true conan yeah
there's um i'm going to be in a cartoon
called bob's burgers on fox that starts
january 9th plug plug plug and um you're
wearing toy story three story three and
shrek and yeah loads of stuff do you
like this is an interesting thing
because uh i think your voice is
fantastic do you how do you feel about
your voice i like it i mean for two
reasons i get to do animation which is a
dream come true and also in my head my
voice sounds completely different from
what it sounds like in the real world
it's really like sultry upstairs
it's like made west it's like oh why
don't you come up and see me sometime
like it's really nice really that's how
you hear your voice
i know and no one else can hear it they
take it to the grave i guess
what does your voice sound like in your
head high and annoying yeah
what a prison yeah i don't like my voice
but i it's my least favorite quality
really well fifth uh we'll get into that
later